-You have one of the great
achievements of any artist
You got a Super Bowl commercia
coming up this year
for Bud Light.
That's a big deal.
-Yes, sir.
You know, it's a big deal for me
because I love football
and I also love beer.
So it's a perfect combination.
-It's a marriage of
your two great loves.
[ Laughs ]
-It's perfect.
-You worked with Bud Light i
the past, but this is sort of --
it's the Bud Light's Legends ad,
and it's bringing back
a lot of spokespeople
from across the year.
There's a -- well, I mean,
Cedric's over here, Caveman.
"I love you, man" guy
I think is in it.
We actually have a short clip,
a early look at
Post's Super Bowl ad.
♪♪♪♪
-Post Malone?
Cedric. Medieval people.
Johnny. Dr. Galazkiewics?
-Yes, I am.
-Still got those moves?
-You know it.
-Alright, Bud Light Legends,
let's do this.
-Very fun.
[ Laughs ]
-I look handsome.
-You look great.
You look wonderful.
-Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you very much.
I'm just trying to keep up
you know?
-Are you -- Where will you
be watching the game?
How will you consume
the football game?
-Oh, probably with queso
or something.
No, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Queso, when you said queso,
you mean melted cheese?
Is that --
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
That's probably how I'll b
consuming the football game.
[ Laughter ]
-See, this is the sort of ho
insider Hollywood gossip we get.
Or Utah gossip.
-This is the good stuff
right here.
No, I don't know.
I'll be at home.
I'll probably be sitting aroun
the bar, playing music.
You know, it's rough.
It was a rough year for me
Just straight --
I'm a Cowboys fan.
-Yeah.
-But I love my boys to death
and I'm proud of my boys,
and I can't wait for next year
and just kick some ass.
Can I say the A-word?
-It's too late.
[ Laughter ]
That's one of those things -
-I almost said it again.
-Well, you know what?
We'll dub in your queso there.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, just kick some queso.
Just text-to-speech it.
-Hey, you got --
Now, you're a Cowboys fan,
but you have
a Kansas City Chiefs tattoo.
-Mm.
-This was due to losing a bet.
-What was the bet,
and how did you lose it?
-Bets and alcohol get involved
and it never turns out good.
I've been to Vegas
too many times to learn that
But somehow, I still do it
-Right.
-Me, Travis Kelce,
and Patrick Mahomes
were playing beer pong,
and they were just crushing us
Like, "It's not fair.
You guys are the best athletes
in the world.
And you guys, like, balls al
the time flying everywhere."
You know what I mean?
So they keep crushing us.
And I'm like, "Listen,"
and I'm drunk and I'm confident.
"If you guys beat us one mor
time, I will get a K.C. logo
with both of your signatures
right next to it."
And here it is right here.
Unfortunately, this is
on my skin forever.
-Gotcha. So, just to track
this back, Post,
you made the bet after they beat
you multiple times in a row.
[ Laughter ]
-It was like four times
in a row.
And I'm like, "Alright,
alright, let's go.
We're coming back, best of 10.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you think the bet would
like, make them nervous?
[ Laughter ]
-I was hoping it would
intimidate them a little bit
but Travis Kelce's like 8'9.
-Was there another side
of the bet?
What would have happened
had you won?
-Just beating the Super Bowl
champions in beer pong, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's the whole thing
I like to sabotage myself.
I like to make one-sided bet
very much, you know?
-Now, obviously, I'm going t
guess the lion's share
of your tattoos
are ones you chose
and you did not get
because you lost a bet.
Do you have any other
bet-losing tattoos?
-Well, as opposed
to popular belief,
all the tattoos on my face
are not from losing bets.
But --
[ Laughs ]
No, I think everything --
I don't think I have
another bet tattoo.
But, you know, anything
that I get is kind of just -
it's very spur of the moment
You know, no matter what.
-You know what?
Don't take this the wrong way.
I believe that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, most definitely.
Whenever you come to Utah,
I'll hook you up with somethin
very beautiful.
-That'd be great.
I mean, I think for a starte
tattoo, I feel like
you'd be a very good perso
to take that journey with.
Hey, Post, it was a deligh
talking to you.
Let's please do it again soon.
-Sure.
-Stay safe out there.
-You as well, sir.
Take it easy. Love you guys.
-Check out budlightlegends.com
to officially join
the Bud Light Legends,
and keep an eye out for
the full commercial
this Sunday
during the Super Bowl.